[Music]
is there anything more exciting than
seeing your favorite Disney characters
come to life we don't think so and these
10 wreck-it Ralph mega fans seem to
agree so if you've ever wondered what
wreck-it Ralph would look like in real
life make sure to stick around until the
end of the video don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this and give this video a big
thumbs up now join us as we take a look
at 10 wreck-it Ralph characters in real
life dr. Eggman
what happens when you combine a
genius-level IQ with a gigantic
moustache well you get dr. Eggman of
course this mustachioed supervillain is
primarily known from his role in the
Sonic the Hedgehog series where he is
constantly trying to take over the world
dr. Eggman was originally designed in
1990 and quickly became one of the most
memorable nemec's in the Sonic series
the character was intended to be the
opposite of Sonic the Hedgehog whereas
Sonic represents good and the natural
world
dr. Eggman represents the world of
development machinery and automation yes
this super villain uses his superior
intelligence to turn the natural world
against itself he has been known to turn
animals into fighting machines and to
summon ancient deities bent on global
destruction although dr. Eggman is
immensely powerful and intelligent Sonic
somehow always manages to thwart his
plans you know what they say you can't
make an omelet without cracking a few
eggs and while dr. Eggman's motives are
surely evil he does have a pretty cool
car called the egg mobile even cooler
than his car is dr. Eggman's awesome
cameo in wreck-it Ralph
although the appearance was brief it was
enough for one fan to get decked out in
full
dr. Eggman costume with a bald head huge
mustache and the villains recognizable
shades this costume totally nails it
rancis Slugger butter if you like candy
as much as we do you would certainly get
along well with rancid Slugger butter
you may remember rancis as one of the
racers from sugar rush on the outside he
seems like he would be the sweetest boy
around
how could someone with a peanutbutter
Cup as a hat not be super nice well
don't judge a book by its cover because
rancis isn't actually all that sweet
that's right this candy loving little
boy actually bullies vanellope for her
status as a glitch bad rancis even
though he may not be a very kind boy
one fan thought he was still memorable
enough to emulate this fan did such an
incredible job dressing up as rancis
that we have to take a closer look one
of the first things you notice about
this young racer is his manicured bright
blond hair this fan really went all out
and somehow found the perfect wig to
capture rancis his signature swooping
curls now if you think that's impressive
just take a look at his hat that's right
this fan managed to put together an
incredible peanut butter cup hat to
complete the outfit let's just hope it
doesn't melt here we can also see that
young rancis is posing for a picture
with none other than glide orange for
Lloyds looking pretty good decked out
with his cane and little pumpkin hat
taffyta muttonfudge
if you weren't watching the movie
closely you may have missed the sweet
but sour taffyta muttonfudge taffeta
appears in the racing games sugar rush
and is known as a highly skilled racer
in fact she is only bested by the one
and only King candy thanks to all of her
racing accomplishments she's developed
quite an ego and a confidence bordering
on arrogance at the same time taffeta is
quite charismatic and is always quick to
put on a sweet face because of that she
is really quite popular did you know
that she is actually the leader of some
of the racers that's right and she
considers candlehead and rancis plugger
butter among some of her closest friends
but don't be fooled by her outgoing
persona as this young lady is as fierce
and competitive as they get along with
rancis taffeta takes every opportunity
to bully and pick on poor vanellope by
the end of the movie though taffeta is
put in her place as it is revealed that
vanellope is actually the rightful ruler
of sugar rush perhaps it is this moment
that our fans chose to replicate with
her costume as you can see it looks like
her mascara is running after a good cry
beyond that the
her outfit is shockingly accurate this
amazing cosplayer has the whole costume
put together including taffetas
strawberry helmet long gloves and bright
pink outfit surge protector if you've
ever been to an airport you've probably
encountered a security guard like surge
protector yes if you have a run-in with
this character you'd better be ready for
random searches questions about any
fruit you might be carrying and a whole
bunch of hassle while this can be a
little bit annoying at times it's best
to remember that he's got a very
important job surge protector is
responsible for checking people into the
game Central Station and boy does he
take his job seriously although he is
very dedicated to keeping the games
central station safe he seems to be
primarily focused on giving Ralph a hard
time almost every time the two meet
surge protector stops Ralph for what he
claims is a random Security check what a
headache still there is actually
something pretty charming about surge
protector did you know that the actor
that voices the character Phil Johnston
is also one of the writers for the film
talk about double duty while the
security guard might not be everyone's
favorite character there was one fan
that liked him enough to paint himself
blue not only did he cover himself and
his hair in blue paint
but he also decked himself out in surge
protectors entire costume complete with
gloves clipboard and a security badge it
looks like this surge protector will
definitely be keeping the game central
stations safe King candy without further
ado we present to you the primary
antagonist from the film king candy you
may remember this candy cane bad guy
from his signature phrase have some
candy with his big bowtie and tiny crown
King candy is the ruler and most
powerful figure in the sugar rush game
before he was at the head of the game he
was actually a very popular character in
an old classic racing game called turbo
time back then he was known as turbo and
he enjoyed a lot of attention and
admiration from his fellow racers when
turbo time eventually faded from
popularity turbo escaped and lied
dormant in the game Central Station
after the
he quickly became the ruler of the new
game and changed his name to King candy
from there he ruled the game with an
iron fist don't you think he looks a
little too sweet to be so evil we did
too but after watching the film we
definitely saw his true colors although
not the most likeable character in the
film one young fan decided to pay
tribute to King candy by replicating his
extremely elaborate costume this young
boy really knocked it out of the park
somehow managing to construct a big
candy bowtie candy cane Walker and puffy
golden shorts he even found a pretty
convincing bald cap now that's
dedication sergeant Calhoun sergeant
Calhoun is a no-nonsense lady and one of
the primary characters in the film
wreck-it Ralph once you know her tragic
backstory it's easy to understand why
Calhoun ended up being so serious it all
started on her wedding night when she
was set to be married to her one true
love
doctor Brad Scott just as the ceremony
was getting underway sergeant Calhoun
realized she'd made a mistake that she
would never forget usually the sergeant
does regular very important perimeter
checks to make sure the space is safe
from sy bugs unfortunately but
understandably she had forgotten to do
one last perimeter check on the day of
her wedding because of this si bug was
able to break into the chapel just as
the bride and groom were exchanging vows
within a moment
the cybo devoured dr brad scott and the
sergeants true love was gone forever
after a grave mistake like that it makes
sense that calhoun would take her job so
seriously
despite her closed-off demeanor this
tough lady is definitely one of the most
inspiring characters in the film she was
so inspiring in fact that one woman
decided to dress up in Calhoun's entire
costume this awesome lady managed to
replicate the Sargent's full suit of
armor her hip haircut and even her large
sigh bug destroying weapon we hope she's
careful with that jewbilee 'no Bingbing
jewbilee 'no Bingbing must be one of the
sweetest razors in the sugar rush her
warm smile and cheerful attitude are
definitely contagious and she is certain
to brighten anyone's day with her kind
and supportive words to match her
pleasant attitude her creators gave her
a complete cherry themed out
this makes total sense since Bing
cherries are one of the sweetest
varietals out there her costume is
completely cherry red and her bright red
hair is always pulled into pigtails with
matching red beads the cherry on top of
course is her cherry shaped helmet that
keeps her extra safe on the track not
only is Jubilee nough Bing Bing
incredibly sweet but she is also one of
the most talented drivers around
throughout the film we see her zipping
and zooming her way to the finish line
like it was easy as pie for the short
time that Jubilee nough Bing Bing is in
the film she never ceases to inspire
hope and enthusiasm
although Jubilee nough is not one of the
central characters of the film one fan
thought she was so sweet that she needed
her own doppelganger that's right and
this fan didn't miss a single detail in
assembling the racers signature outfit
she's got it all the bright red pigtails
with matching beads the white t-shirt
with two cherries on it and even the
sugared cherry helmet vanellope von
schweetz it's time to show some respect
because we're about to talk about the
true ruler of sugar rush vanellope von
schweetz although this sweet young lady
is the game's rightful leader she is
actually viciously bullied throughout
most of the film that's because before
the story in wreck-it Ralph begins the
evil King candy uses his powers to alter
vanilla pees coat and turn her into a
foolish this programming change makes it
so that the other racers don't want her
or her glitches anywhere near the races
even worse several of the other racers
in the film viciously pick on her for
being different
all of this bullying leaves vanellope
feeling outcasted and as a result she
develops a defensive attitude and a
sassy disposition underneath her heart
and exterior however is a powerful and
talented racer that is intent on proving
her worth to the other racers above all
else it is this intense enthusiasm to be
accepted by her peers that ultimately
leads her to regain her status as the
ruler of sugar rush one fan obviously
recognized vanilla peas true valiance
and decided to completely replicate her
costume this young lady did an
incredible job dressing up in a hip
green sweater
tying her ponytail up with a bright red
cloth and placing various little treats
in her dark black hair she looks just
like vanilla pea does in the film fix-it
Felix jr. no matter what wreckit-ralph
Rex
fix-it Felix jr. is always there to fix
it this energetic and super positive
character is definitely one of our
favorites from the film how could you
not love this hammer-wielding heroic
maintenance man that is consistently
there to save the day we know we
certainly couldn't get enough of him in
fact did you know that Felix jr. was
actually originally going to be the main
character and hero of the film that's
right he only ended up a supporting role
because writer Phil Johnston decided
that Ralph would be a more compelling
lead pretty cool right even though he's
not the main character of racket Ralph
Felix jr. is a major part of the film
and a perfect example of a true hero his
demeanor is always humble and his outfit
speaks to his everyman persona yes Felix
jr. truly represents the best in all of
us and the light that shines on the
world through the kind Souls that chose
to follow it we were so excited to see
that one young boy decided to suit up
and give Felix jr. the love he deserves
you better believe this costume is on
point from the light blue polo to the
dark blue cap this young fan really
captured the spirit of Felix jr. he even
got a hold of his very own magic hammer
wreck-it Ralph if we're talking about
the wreck-it ralph universe we
definitely can't leave out the not so
gentle giant himself wreck-it Ralph
after all the whole movie was named
after him before we get too deep into
his costume let's talk a bit about who
Ralph is as a character this big wrecker
is the primary antagonist of the
fictional video game fix-it Felix jr.
because of this role Ralph has always
been known as the bad guy at a certain
point the muscular man decides he's
tired of being known as a villain and
sets off on a journey to prove that he's
not actually as bad as he seems
in fact his whole goal is to become the
hero of a video game and to protect
vanellope along the way doesn't seem so
bad does it beyond his ambitions Ralph
also has a pretty charming costume his
muscular arms bust out of
if flannel t-shirt and a pair of
overalls that always seem to be
partially unbuckled nothing seems to fit
right do you know it also doesn't seem
to fit racket routes role as the villain
obviously doesn't seem to fit his dreams
and intentions perhaps sensing Ralph's
good spirit deep down one young fan went
the whole nine yards and did an
incredible job of reproducing his outfit
this kid got the costume down perfect
capturing Ralph's huge muscles partially
undone overalls and even his spiky hair
is there a wreck it Ralph character that
you'd like to see in real life let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
[Music]